Regardez bien ce caillou : c'est ce qu'on
appelle une bombe !
Pas de panique, il s'agit d'un lambeau de lave
qui s'est refroidi et solidifié durant sa chute
au moment d'une éruption.
Je l'ai ramassé sur les pentes de
l'Etna, le volcan sicilien.
La lave est projetée par les gaz contenus dans la
chambre magmatique qui, en remontant,
se détendent comme les bulles de champagne et poussent la matière en fusion à l'extérieur.
Le trajet de cette bombe
a été suffisamment long pour que la lave,
très fluide au départ, tourne sur
elle-même et prennent la forme d'une goutte.
Ce petit bourrelet témoigne du
mouvement : j'adore cette roche !
vous vous rendez compte : elle est restée confinée
des milliards d'années avant de mettre le nez dehors.
Allez à demain et surtout n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes tous confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...